so about a month ago i got myself a loop
pedal and i think it's safe to say that
i've been a little obsessed
[Music]
this past month i've been traveling
around a bunch and i've been looping
everywhere
and that is my sister literally
playing the freaking keyboard
near london bridge while it's raining
[Music]
okay you start
um
[Music]
but i have to press i basically press it
and then i start playing you press that
at the same time
how is it gonna get the first thing that
i play
it just does
[Music]
whenever i get hooked on something new i
tend to go overboard and i spend a
ridiculous amount of time trying to
figure things out experimenting with it
and just becoming familiar with the
gadget or
the concept or whatever it is that i'm
i'm working with and that's exactly what
happened with looping and this month
happened to be a month where i was on
the road a lot i was traveling a bunch
and i didn't have regular access to a
piano to work on so this was a perfect
opportunity for me to just work on the
little keyboard with the loop pedal and
this was a portable setup sort of
and i just had fun with it wherever i
went
this station is waterloo change here for
the bakery northern and waterloo and
city line and national rail services
if you do everything all at once you're
never going to want to travel again
miss a lot of
stuff when you're looping you're
basically layering multiple parts
together with the use of a loop pedal
which allows you to capture a musical
idea with the press of a button
the device will then repeat it
automatically and from there on out you
can continue adding layers for as long
as you want
here you can see me pushing the button
at the exact start of the first loop
and again at the end
this phrase will now continue to repeat
on its own
now i'm recording the second loop
[Music]
a third loop
[Music]
a fourth loop
[Music]
and so on and so forth
certain loop pedals allow you to have
more freedom and control over this
process but for now the loop pedal i
have only allows for the very basic
functions of looping with the option of
being able to delete the most recent
track if so desired
yeah thank you i was trying to do that
like is that how you do it
if you if you press and hold it erases
okay cool cool my current setup involves
a keyboard
a quarter inch cable connecting it to
the input of a loop pedal
another quarter inch cable connecting
the keyboard to a recording device
and a third cable connecting the output
of the loop pedal to the recorder
there's also a power cable for the loop
pedal that i plug into a portable
battery pack since i'm usually using the
setup on the go lastly when looping with
a friend i use a simple headphone jack
splitter that plugs directly into the
recorder
i will say all of this
combined
is pretty heavy and
that was a struggle
understanding how the loot pedal itself
works wasn't so complicated i actually
thought it would be much more complex
than it actually is
probably took a few hours to figure out
the setup and get used to
actually pushing the button with my feet
or my hand but beyond that i started to
notice some challenges related to
looping
[Music]
i was starting to notice the difference
between musical ideas that sound good on
their own
when heard once versus ideas that sound
good looped and actually have the kind
of momentum that
makes you want to hear it over and over
again and certain musical ideas are
appropriate for this and certain musical
ideas aren't it's kind of hard to
articulate what exactly it is but the
best i can think of is the simpler the
better
also just the very nature of looping
deciding to repeat an idea
puts pressure on whatever you're going
to introduce into the track because
whatever it is you're going to be having
to listen to it over and over again if
you choose to loop it because of this i
definitely started to think more about
what kinds of ideas i'll introduce into
the track
as a new layer
and
i also realize how easy it is to ruin a
loop just by introducing something that
doesn't fit into what's already there
and it's very easy to overcrowd what's
happening
so all of these things became especially
apparent when i tried to improvise loops
with other people
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
sounds like a ringtone
needless to say the types of loops we
came up with varied in terms of quality
and style and
everything else you can imagine
[Music]
so
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
this experience taught me a lot in a
short period of time about looping
improvising
sound frequency all these things that
i previously didn't think too much about
i think it comes down to like what can
you salvage though can you salvage a bad
baseline
i think it's harder than salvaging a bad
high frequency line
i think you're right
somehow you can take that and as long as
you can keep going under
yeah maybe the delay whenever you
increase or you shorten the time it
increases pitch of the delay and
whenever you decrease the time and it
decreases the pitch so like you know
it's usually better for acoustic delay
but
because it's like slightly
[Music]
and when would you use drive
[Music]
so it's delaying that i have no idea
what it's doing but it's cool
a lot of times during these sessions
there would be a musical idea that
either one of us would introduce into
the loop that at first sounds a bit off
or
maybe not as ideal but
when repeated enough times it started to
grow on on myself and usually the other
person and we found that pretty
fascinating all right well
cool
there you go
you know we let it play long enough and
it's right
you know
you let it loop enough times and it's
the way it's supposed to be
i think the lesson we learned here is
that
there's no such thing as a mistake if
you do it a thousand times
i also got some tips on layering with
frequency in mind again going back to
the point about how it's easy to
overcrowd a loop
that's an interesting challenge to see
how much you can add until it gets just
too chaotic and too messy
so if if you're dealing with a live
looping situation with just this
and making music it'd be interesting to
differentiate okay i wanna i want that
in there but i don't want it to loop
[Music]
here you can notice that i'm playing
some notes that i don't choose to loop
until the last bit
[Music]
it's something i think a lot about now
the actual frequency of an instrument
versus just the pitch
and
that's something that i think
will help
build these loops and get them to be as
big as possible but without layering too
much in the same frequency range because
there's the pitch aspect of it but as we
start switching instruments
the timbre of the instrument will
actually affect um
how much of the buildup
will uh
will exist so you're not stacking on top
of the same frequency yeah in the same
space exactly exactly because the
particular loop pedal that i've been
using is not quantized there have been a
lot of timing quirks for example in the
beginning of this loop
[Music]
there's something irregular about the
beat and the phrase that later on seem
to have disappeared
[Music]
you can see here by noticing adam's knee
that we're sort of rounding our beats to
feel a steady pulse
i think there's something to be said
here about how natural it is for us to
latch on to a regular pulse and find
steadiness in the rhythm
[Music]
in this case a lot of the layers that
adam and i were adding on after the
first few had more of a regular pulse
more presence
and what ended up happening is that the
irregularities that were there
beforehand were being overpowered by
something more steady
[Music]
so
[Music]
how did we come up with the regular
meter it started off
slightly off
yeah it's like
10 or 5.
[Music]
it started out kind of like almost
[Music]
to candy
[Music]
i got that from you
stole that
i like that one that's a nice one yeah i
like i like the uh
when we weren't looping like just
playing that was that was nice it's also
interesting to note the difference
between a loop that is
created in performance style
and a loop that is created in sort of a
workshop style something that came up
quite frequently in conversation was to
decide whether to do a loop in a
performance style
versus a sort of workshop style where
you would try out different things
maybe
test out some sounds and then decide to
loop
a specific idea whereas in a performance
style loop the track from beginning to
end
with all of
the loops and non-loops are a part of
the whole performance basically
[Music]
[Music]
for me the performance style looping was
much more fun
because it ended up feeling like a game
there was a lot of pressure it was time
sensitive
and i think at one point jeff and i
decided that we wouldn't let a loop pass
for more than one or two times max
before
adding something new it's like speed
chess
so this in and of itself made this whole
process very stimulating and a lot of
fun
before i continue on i really need to
thank adam jeff and joe for being
awesome looping partners and for being a
part of this video
if you're not familiar with them already
which would be quite surprising i highly
recommend you checking out their
channels
[Music]
oh
no
it's a good take too
hold on
it might still be there
also a very special thank you to my
brother jun
[Applause]
who made a bulk of all of this traveling
recently not only possible but very
one-of-a-kind and memorable
[Music]
[Music]
i do this with one of my friends gary
absolutely fantastic it's like i'm not
sleeping don't worry
but you were just
[Music]
so during the first few weeks i was
intrigued with this process of looping
and i was using this pedal to work on
different methods of creating tracks in
the past week i've been using the loop
pedal in terms of a more functional tool
to work on improvisation and timing
for example here i came up with a loop
that has a lot of gaps
[Music]
so improvising on top of it helps me
stay disciplined about subdividing in my
head so that i don't end up getting off
and it's really easy to get off because
the value of the subdivisions are quite
small
[Music]
and the gaps make it hard to
keep track of it
so this has been really revealing to me
in terms of all of my timing issues
i also want to explore ways to create
loops with a different kind of form
something that's more complex and with a
different kind of structure rather than
just relying on
layering a bunch of things and then
fading out at the end
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so that pretty much wraps up my first
month of looping
i'm excited to explore further with this
little device and work on the things i
mentioned in this video thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
you